we are uh bringing somebody back
somebody from the jesus did a long long
ago the early days of day wave when it
was just me by myself on the stupid show
and now i'm doing a show with stupider
people so it makes me feel smarter do
you miss it uh not really
uh no this is waiting oh ben is back huh
it's not bad yeah it's not chicken
it's not b frog it's i wish it's not e
frog dr o ah [ __ ] no it's not dr o
doctor who's been a while
well let's see if i'm just going to play
this this song that pessy actually made
two years ago to introduce the person
who is back in our lives
[Music]
oh yeah they're stoked
i put on my favorite dress
in the bathroom i hide psoriasis on my
hands and legs i hear my brother waking
up
time to film him from a shadowy corner
of a room
this house
[Music]
he beats me in this house this house
[Music]
he beats me in this feeling hungry need
to eat
oh no we're out of health burritos
they're my favorite lunch treat father
offers to order me
my very own pizza but it's not from
where i like
this house
he beats me in this house this house
[Music]
he beats me in this
this house
he beats me in this house this house
[ __ ] human being he beats me in this
look at that pessy when he used to try
it was great um
there's a young spry content creator
ready to take home no i know and then
you broke me now he's broken like
everybody else let's check out dayton's
first
unlisted video it's been six months it's
been six months since we've seen him
since he's graced our screen since we've
seen one of the alphas
of all the people that we've ever
covered and rotc gets a lot of credit
for covering dayton but dayton don't
ever forget dayton was a
day wave exclusive that i graciously
brought up
to rotc
he's secretly filming people by the way
of course listen he hasn't changed much
no
okay
wow listen to that terrible family
listen to those grandparents taking care
of the grandchildren they're horrible i
can't wait to see why he's going to be
mad
oh i want to point something else out
i haven't seen these videos
on purpose
he's moved on from the brother to the
sister now from what was like yes
oh yeah oh should i i'll read the title
i was kind of just about to say i should
read the title my sister and
brother-in-law leave thanksgiving
audibly mocking bye to me thinking i
don't hear them
[Music]
no watch
no one said anything to him
what is that room of horror i'm saying
bye to me down there why were they even
that was their attempt to say goodbye to
me they made zero attempt to communicate
with dayton they were saying goodbye to
the people that were in front of them
first off
why wouldn't anybody want to try to say
bye to you when you're [ __ ] moping in
your room and saying your entire family
beats you like i love that he thinks
that on top of all that they need to go
be nice to him
you've literally put their [ __ ] on the
internet and honestly i have this in it
i think you're you helped you helped
kill your brother
pretty sure he did tonight
all the stress
were they never make any attempt to
approach
that's my brother-in-law
oh that black brother-in-law remember
him
he looks like reggie no he's not reggie
he's the he's
oh god he does
he does kind of
he's reggie watts
that's my brother-in-law he walks by
[Music]
that's my brother-in-law he's on james
corden's show now for some reason which
is
weird who does not make any effort
amid violence that's my sister
it's my brother-in-law he makes beats in
this house
and there's a little hat breed he makes
beats in this house
they're not called half breeds they're
called i didn't say anything wrong with
lockers
oh sorry
she just saw me on camera let me turn
him up a bit
she's aware there we go
oh my god let hola go back to go back to
when he's filming the sister-in-law just
that whole thing he goes that's my
sister that's my sister he goes she saw
me on camera
she's aware and he runs through
the best touch all right
here we go here we go
the effort
amid violence that's my sister
and she just saw me on camera
she's aware
she's aware gotta go gotta run gotta go
oh god they saw me they saw me gotta go
i gotta go i gotta run i gotta run
you have been found you have been down
by the way i know there's a lot of new
people that might not know the date and
hyper and over things so i'll just
i can it's too long right sum it up
if you go to rotc clips i made an entire
playlist in order of every time that on
day wave or rotc we've ever talked about
dayton hypernova but he uh
lives in dayton ohio
uh
he is trans
he's a man who became a woman
but still in every way is a man but but
he also still likes girls can you link
me this video please i have an edit idea
for please send me oh he also has a un
healthy sub uh
obsession with uh was there a name again
oh uh uh nicole ricci yeah
crazy obsession all right there you go
oh thank you so much oh thank you
um all right now pesce's going to be
quiet for five minutes he makes out his
masterpiece
oh god he got an ipad yep
somebody upgraded
oh upgrading
i don't like i don't like that he films
using the ipad because i prefer his hand
on his hip holding the phone up thing
that he did
because that's my favorite my favorite
uh
uh stance that he has he still looks
like the dude from son-in-law yeah
nothing's true
polly sure yeah
louise oh he's trans so be paula sure
yeah there you go
you can see the look on her face
she did not say anything she looked and
she realized and regret what she loves
speech is still slurred like he's still
on drugs well he is on drugs
nobody said anything
to you because nobody wants to be around
you you're a [ __ ] again i say this
again
the things that you've done that we've
watched remember that time
that he got mad that his dad didn't
order pizza from the right pizza place
even though his dad was paying for it he
just got [ __ ] living and screamed at
him remember the fight that they had at
the outback steakhouse
remember that one yep
that was my favorite one
remember when he broke a full wine glass
on his brother's head
and the oats and called that he was uh
the sherman was abusing him
remember when i pretended to be dr phil
and he bought it
all those classic moments yeah
rotc you think she looked
i'm exposed to the goddamn business
and she realized and regret what she's
allowed to happen
oh is she real okay so that that little
look that pessy pointed out that little
look that she just
looked at him for a second in that whole
time he's explaining her internal
monologue let's hear it because we
weren't even paying attention let's hear
her this is what he thinks his sister
was thinking here we go
my sister just saw me on camera
in the window
you can see the look on her face
she did not say anything she looked and
she realized and regret what she's
allowed to happen
i do not stop recording everything in
this house so now i'm kind of in danger
of her because i don't know what she
does at that point when she gets that
irrational from her
guilt that she won't face as her guilt
wait a minute didn't she say this about
[ __ ] what's his name that dad from
liberty yeah i was sherman but see now
it's not sherman anymore because
sherman's dead so he can't blame his
dead brother so now he's blaming his
alive sister
just just ask him doesn't she live like
right across the street
literally literally
the house right across the street and
i'm remembering didn't we have contact
with uh the family have
and oh
no still
i don't want to out who in the family
because there's actually believe it or
not it's actually a pretty big family
yeah uh
but yes i do have contact i mean i'll
just put it to you this way
these videos are unlisted and you only
post them on his personal facebook page
anyone else's but her guilt for her
choices
absolutely disgusting
now maybe just maybe she just saw me in
the window but she didn't see the camera
in my hand i don't know
yeah she's guys guys guys hold on a
second
she didn't see this humongous ipod
in his hand
he's not he's acting like he was
secretly recording like this is a micro
camera
jesus christ
but i'm pretty sure she's all a damn
camera
she knows that she is guilty and that
look in her face is saying it all right
there that's absolutely disgusting
transphobia
hey guys don't don't mind me i'm uh
i'm just uh recording i think i think
jj's recording us guys guys i think jj's
guys
guys [ __ ] jj stop recording jj stop
recording i'm fighting back no stop no
no
no
nope
all right now you're now you're all
being recorded all right now i'm
doubling you're being recorded you're
double recorded no i don't like that
i i don't have another only have one in
here yeah stop it and it's keying it out
stop it [ __ ] stop i got it
okay
i'm recording you no stop that's a sweet
that's a nintendo switch stop hey it
doesn't matter yes hey hey yeah [ __ ]
stop
all right
all right [ __ ] it's all stop it
get it i don't have three hands jj my
co-hosts are being transphobic right now
it's on they are being
transphobic
fine you win jj you win for now
her guilt for her choices
absolutely disgusting
now maybe just maybe she just saw me in
the window but she didn't see the camera
in my hand i don't know
but i'm pretty sure she's on a damn
camera
she knows that she is guilty and that
look in her face is saying it all right
there that's absolutely disgusting
trans phobia
and racism by the way
black husband i want to point out that
his sister that sister black husband
mulatto kids okay i don't know that
seems like a dated term
um
pap bridge is the corrector sorry thank
you half breed mulatto kids
uh she's got a black husband with a big
drip and hog
and i can't say stopping bush anymore no
no that's gross
and and
again
accusing them of being racist and
transphobic all she did and you guys all
saw it you all saw it with your eyes
all she did was walk by the window she
didn't say a word
she didn't do anything to him
that's all you had to do that's all that
had to happen
in the family
in our brother-in-law and not in the
family it's in the familia is how you
say it all right
family friendly
family
allowing that kind of stuff to happen
it's absolutely disgusting these people
are all guilty of sin
they're all guilty
but i thought you were an atheist
yeah but he's also crazy so i mean you
know piccolaine
oh he's here's angry size you want to
hear oh let's hear his angry sighs here
we go
that's a forced fake angry side by you
know what i mean like that's not even
real
[Music]
i'm so angry
i'm so angry i could kill my brother
i just want you i'm gonna kill my sister
next wait he just went through oh let me
already just said hold on
and it's not your guy's fault he just
[ __ ] whispers
so angry
i just went through thanksgiving sting
in my bedroom in my bed not eating at
all there you go rice no i thank you
nobody nobody made you do that
two days straight
i mean they were walking out with like
[ __ ] trays of food dude
acting like violence doesn't
ruin families
and it does yeah but you're still on
this dayton dayton you ruined families
you wrote it pessy what did you make
midfield my sister
she just saw me on camera okay that was
really good
playing it again
she just saw me on camera
she's aware
rebel gravel scrabble scramble
dated
[Laughter]
well the good thing is
the good thing is is that
well the bad thing is that video is over
the good thing is is that we have
another one oh yeah yes more we have
another one
we have another one
oh he couldn't help himself
secretly filming this is uh
thanksgiving my bigot obese sister talks
about other starve how about about how
others starve how good uncle dale was
ironic
he's good at titles you got to give him
that
very descriptive
okay that's a kid
so as you could hear they're just
you know talking like normal
thanksgiving
here we go here we go ready here we go
here we go i think they're talking about
my uncle dale right now downstairs and
they were talking about how great a man
he was and how he was always there to
help people now dayton is the reason you
didn't film anything for six months
because you don't want to
or because maybe you're at a place that
didn't allow you to have phones
what do you mean by that that's a good
theory
all i'm saying is break his phone
all i'm saying is is that since we've
been covering him
we have had
police
uh social workers
people from the local government come
over and try to talk to him because he's
a known problem
and sometimes when you're a problem for
so long they go look you need a little
alone time
a little time out will you have your own
little room
where somebody's putting cheetos on your
clothes
take your cheetos off of my
clothes get your cheetos off of my ipad
right now
you transphobe
and this is ironic because these are all
people who are allowed to skin he beats
me he beats me with his cheetos
in his crew pope he beats me at this
group home
if he's in this room with these cheetos
because these are all people who allow
the skinhead to beat me in front of them
he's dead he's dead f in the chat for
sherman everybody he's been dead for a
year yeah nope his ghost is back oh
nothing better than ever
like what at what point do you move on
bud who's gonna do the ghost ad
photoshop
sherman standing over top of him
a lot of skin hit listen i'm going to
tell you something right now
if one of you crazy [ __ ]
takes the scene from the movie ghost
and puts dayton on the girl all right
and put sherman
on patrick swayze
i'm gonna be a very happy man
beat me in front of them over and over
again over the span seven years old he
lived here drinking himself to death and
then get exposed by these people wow
seven years he was beat that's that's
exactly how long punk was away from
wrestling
coincidence
by my parents
they got covered and exposed him to it
when he had a compromise immune system
from his drinking
so you're thinking are you blaming
excuse me are you blaming your parents
for giving your brother covid
that skinhead was beating me over the
span of seven years
you're st this guy you lost your villain
i get it
but you lost your villain you can't keep
trying to find ways to bring him back to
be the bad guy in your story that's the
other reason he's probably off the
internet for so long he didn't have a
villain anymore
well he didn't have a joker nope all
children over to this house so his
children are walking around the house
you know
unless we figure here was sherman really
the villain
no no no no i don't think he's but to
him like all right now hold on hold on
is he saying is he saying that kids are
walking around the house spreading
covered
uh yes that's correct that is what he's
saying he wants nobody to be happy on
thanksgiving
oh is that his new thing now sherman's
gone so now he's gonna be a [ __ ]
covet soldier he's a coveted soldier now
yeah that's the thing
that's his next thing because get the
jab
yeah i don't think so i think he did i
think he did i'm almost positive we'll
see
so all of that behave but he never
leaves the house but i stay in my
bedroom during because it's crazy how
bad it was and it's still pretty much
crazy just being around anything i can't
get the jab because i'm autoimmune
because if they if they give me the
needle i'm hemophiliac and my blood is
thin like my hair and i won't stop
bleeding and then they'll have to take
me to the hospital and then they'll beat
me there
but okay first off can i have a health
burrito please i'm weak
that's crazy
well he's dead
so you got your wish
we thought that bingo card
well i gotta find it i have it somewhere
huh
it's that beat
yeah i kind of dig it man
okay
uh linda made something i'll check
there you go
he couldn't find feet so he made his
hands bigger
i'll put it for a second all right back
to the bathroom we go keep wondering
what that sound is that pounding sound
downstairs it's called people having fun
is what that's
it's children frolicking
it's a kid without a fidget spinner yeah
exactly like that's the problem
brother-in-law hitting his knees
constantly pretending to play drums
because he's a musician
i'm
the nerve the goal wow
bro
do me a favor give me the phone number
to the dayton police department i didn't
know that i'm gonna get this this black
man shot because this black man cannot
beat on his bongos from the jungle i'm a
musician as well and this man a loud man
twice my size maybe they're playing that
donkey kong bongos game remember that
game
oh can you imagine if he looks at him
and says the wrong thing that dude's not
gonna be like sherman he's going to be
no that dude's a problem that he would
[ __ ] his world up like he's good first
off he wouldn't give a [ __ ] he [ __ ] him
up he's black they're not going to [ __ ]
they don't [ __ ] care
he's also a musician
in the same social groups and that man
allows that kind of [ __ ] to happen to me
so i'm sorry what does this knee
drumming have to do with you getting
beat up by your ghost brother
listen to those children those maniacs
having fun savages
[Music]
by the way let me put this out there
taper if you're listening i'm gonna clip
this
just so you know
uh
and since uh my clip guy has a job now
can you do me a favor
can you look at my thumbnail and make me
a thumbnail for this thank you title i'm
thinking of is dayton's amazing
thanksgiving return thanks
oh wait wait wait wait wait did you just
say
he's got a job so he's not working
anymore oppressor i mean which one the
forehead or the other one forehead
forehead oh well [ __ ] that guy good for
him that he has a job don't be a dick
about it i'm just saying
well he should do both all right here we
go
he's got time it's not like he's got a
woman
and back i'm thinking about one meal a
day they're talking about one meal a day
down there i lived on one meal a day
while that man was beating me i lived on
one meal they left health burritos and
pete's only the pizza that i liked
you wouldn't be living on a one-day meal
kind of thing sorry one meal a day if
you went downstairs and had thanksgiving
dinner this remember last year they had
this whole spread
for thanksgiving we covered it like they
bought like it was a lot of food right
and he didn't want any of it and even
his dad was like well dayton we'll just
we have all this cornbread and we got
all the butt up and he's like no i'm not
eating that i'm not eating that i'm not
getting it it has nuts in it [ __ ] you
know what else has nuts in it his mouth
technically i think it was about half of
a meal a day living in this house
because i was working below minimum wage
trying to earn enough money to get the
hell out of here the only reason i'm
still used to okay can i can i also say
something
100
for doing laundry
is not a job sir no
no that's not that's that's first off
that's an allowance this is what you're
getting you're getting an email
who should be doing that for rent for
free you should be doing it for free and
thanking them every day that you're 30
hells you know
35
35 or 36
and you are still in their home
last year in 2020 that crazy pandemic
that's still going on technically it's
crazy
is he mad at the pain that is the
pandemic beater
he's saying the pandemic is the reason
why he's still there oh oh
oh oh oh how [ __ ] dare you
how dare you how [ __ ] dare you the
pandemic is the reason you're still
there yeah
piece of [ __ ]
what happened to your remember what
happened to your business plan where
you're gonna have a store where
everything's for free
remember that
hey what happened to your aluminum foil
art installation what's going on with
that is it doing good huh
huh how's it doing
uh taper ass is asking if this is the
thumbnail that you want these people
okay i'm gonna look sister is laughing
about how much she ate because she's
overweight by a lot she's morbidly obese
almost also i put a ghost sherman in one
of them
i like okay let's actually check these
out
we got a little more of this video but i
would like i i always need little breaks
with him because he he's just all right
this is a lean lean and means of course
made his hands huge
uh
this is
what is this this is just a picture of
him that well
tapers asking if that's that that should
be the thumbnail
yeah that's fine but i want it to look
like my other thumbnails if that makes
sense on the clips channel
uh and uh
hey there's uh
there's ghosts
[Music]
there's the ghost
he spooks me in this house
that's racist his brother is a
oh my god
she's over spook weight by a lot she's
morbidly obese almost
she's big enough to she is large enough
that she could have fought my skinhead
brother because she's built like a
football player and she allowed it i'm
sorry you think a fat woman could just
beat up a boxer
yeah especially when they didn't have
anything to do with the fight yeah i
think that's how that happens
in a household relationship you think so
yeah
all right fair enough
to beat me she stayed out of it she
stayed neutral and she has a rainbow
flag on her house that's crazy
just because she supports the
community doesn't mean she can't hate
you
yeah but remember something and i think
it's important to point this out that
we've talked about it
we've talked about it on
the show they hate him they remember the
entire lgbt community
hate him
they hate him i mean like they [ __ ]
cannot [ __ ] stand him
so you know
i gotta rid of that one because i don't
know who's coming back
somehow they can probably overhear me
just a little bit because i'm loud
enough i'm so angry right now
that's horrible
[Music]
[Applause]
on this week's transition impossible
[Music]
on this week's episode of dayton you're
and my impossible is black that's crazy
[ __ ]
yeah that there's black people in this
neighborhood
what the [ __ ] man
wait there's what that's crazy there's
black people that live here that's so
gross what do we [ __ ] talking about
dayton what did he say
he's bla i'm backing it up there's black
people that are here here
be careful that you're okay let's grab
my grandpa's yes
these people about a skinhead racist
bigot to beat me and my brother-in-law
is black that's crazy [ __ ] it's
crazy that he's black
what are the black people in ohio
what
dayton what
he shaved his head and bullied his loser
brother yeah he's not a nazi no
he's an older brother is what he is
skin had to be violent to a trans person
in their own where you bring your small
children do you see that i'm angry about
this no that's horrible no these people
have not made any attempt to interact
with me through any of these things it's
thanksgiving weekend and these people
have made zero effort to communicate
because
you're like well it's like it's like
it's like it's like inviting someone
over to see your new pet cat right and
you're like
oh oh no no she's shy and it's like the
cat just never comes out from under like
the couch
so you just
ignore it that's
he
we in the in the
years now that we've been watching him
has he ever done anything that would
make you feel welcomed
you know what i mean to to go talk to
him like why would you go bother the
troll in his troll cave you know like
i'd leave him alone
i know that i'm in this house they are
absolutely 100 certain that i am in this
house then [ __ ] leave
then [ __ ] leave
then [ __ ] leave
oh royce there's a deadly pandemic out
there then [ __ ] leave
upstairs they just avoid all things they
avoid confrontation they avoid
apologizing even once in their lives for
anything this is god awful
i can't leave because no one will hire
him to do their laundry oh you're right
you're right right yeah has he tried
applying at a dry cleaner
i mean just an idea
all right that would involve time away
from his and he can't be a project he's
doing he can't he can't be around the
chemicals on the count of his dry skin
i keep it all on river because that's
horrible these people are getting sued
up their asses
oh he's suing now this is a new one this
is a new one he's never threatened to
sue
he's going to sue people now
so he's going to sue people who are
who owned his domicile
oh getting beat up seven years
ago i was so confused
how this works
welcome to the people's court
with judge royce lopez
[Music]
the defendant a loving midwestern family
who do nothing but help out their son
the plaintiff
a trans lunatic who has really really
really really really dry skin flakes all
over the place refuses to work is hated
not only by the straight but the entire
gay community of an entire town and says
his black brother-in-law isn't black
enough
oh
trans court
[Music]
prosecutor pessi the narrator the
narrator like continues also i mean like
look at him i mean seriously look i'm
supposed to be impartial here but have
you seen this guy
[Music]
those claws are huge
awesome guys
i motioned the plaintiff come out from
under the table
stop filming please
sir judge homophobic judge here this
he beats me in this court uh actually
judge i go by the name cage paradox yeah
listen earl go sit the [ __ ] down all
right do you hear me
sit the [ __ ] down
all right sir why are you filming me
we're we're being filmed by eight
cameras i get you say they beat you in
this house but if you don't sit down and
shut the [ __ ] up girl you're gonna get
beat in this courthouse
in the years
in the years of covering him
how did no one ever do earl in court
early court is the best right
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] judge watford just starts
beating him with his gavel just
relentlessly
backing him on his [ __ ] stupid head i
said order
honor the defender sherman hypernova has
been dead for a year
and then he just walpner just wipes his
hands with a rag throws it on and he
tells bailiff get this piece of [ __ ] out
of my face
[Music]
the skinhead nazi judge beat me another
win for the nazis speak up you're
whispering this is a courthouse i need
to be able to hear you
how [ __ ]
[Music]
people are real
the people are real his gender is not
judge judy just looks at him and i
i don't like you you freak me out
you got big hands i'm an immediate rule
for the defendant right away just by
looking at you
oh [ __ ]
just keep crying it's just oh welcome
back
uh mr hypernova you said he beat you in
this house yes he came back
and he repeat me wake up i i see you you
always do it actually
the judge should speak up sir
so he
anyway he he would come to this house
put down your phone
now he'd come
down
i still see it
at least put it under the table
i don't know if your mic would still
capture it but you have to can you just
like stand far from it in the corner of
your camera so we only see a little bit
of you
okay i could do this ready
[Music]
mr hypernova uh what did the plaintiff
uh what did the plaintiff do
you don't see your phone sir
[Music]
also we can't hear you
are you hiding from someone
[Music]
he beat me
in this house
and
and
and my brother
is black wait where did he get another
phone and
check his prison pocket he
[Music]
day waves back ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
oh yeah right he's not allowed to film
in the courthouse so he just has an
easel in front of him and he's just
quickly drawing as he talks
have fun with that blue stall by the way
oh man
oh please don't forget all for the love
of god this is a good one to do just do
the people's court thing